DEEPTO CHAKRABARTY:
Now that we've
seen how to describe
a rotating vector,
we can use that to analyze
the motion of our gyroscope.
So again, I'll draw a side
view of my pivot, my rod.
Here's the wheel.
I'll call this point
S. That's a distance d.
And we'll assume that
the angular velocity is
in that direction, so that
the spin angle velocity
vector is pointing outwards
in the plus r hat direction.
That's the k hat direction and
theta hat is into the screen.
Now, again, the weight
is acting downwards
at the center of
mass of the wheel.
There's a normal
force acting upwards.
So the spin angular momentum
with respect to point S
is just equal to the
moment of inertia
of the disk about
its center of mass
times the angular
speed of the spin,
and that's directed in
the plus r hat direction.
And this is the angular
momentum with respect
to point S. Now, the torque
with respect to point S, again,
it's R cross F
relative to point S.
That's going to be Mgd in
the plus theta hat direction.
And for a fast omega, if omega
is a large angular speed,
and therefore if
the angular momentum
vector is a large
vector, then the torque,
which acts perpendicular
to the angular momentum,
will cause the angular
momentum vector to rotate.
And so as a rotating
vector, we can
write that the
magnitude of the time
derivative of that
rotating vector
is equal to the angular
velocity of the rotation
times the length of that vector.
And this is Ls.
And so the length of that vector
is just I times little omega,
and then we multiply
that by capital omega.
Now, this quantity here,
dL dT, is the torque.
So that's the magnitude
of the torque.
But the torque we said is
equal to Mgd in the theta hat
direction.
And so the torque,
Mgd, is equal to I
little omega times big omega.
So I can solve for big omega.
And big omega, which is the
angular speed of rotation
of the angular
momentum vector, is
Mgd divided by moment of
inertia, I, times little omega.
Now recall, little omega
is the angular velocity,
the angular speed of the spin
of the disk or the wheel.
Capital omega is
the angular speed
of the rotation of the
angular momentum vector.
It basically tells
us the speed at which
the center of mass of the wheel
orbits around the vertical axis
through the pivot.
We call capital omega the
precessional angular velocity.
So the precessional angular
velocity is capital omega.
And notice that the
faster little omega
is, the bigger little omega
is, the slower the precession
angular velocity is.
Now, this expression
tells us what
the magnitude of
capital omega is,
what the magnitude of that
precessional angular velocity
is, but it doesn't tell us which
way the system is processing,
whether say, viewed
from the top,
the motion is clockwise
or counterclockwise,
or equivalently, which way
the vector, capital omega,
is pointing.
We know it must point
along the vertical axis,
but does it point upwards,
in the plus K hat direction
or downwards in the
minus K hat direction.
To see that, we need to look at
which way the angular momentum
vector is rotating.
And there are two possibilities.
So let's again go to a
top view of our gyroscope.
So suppose here is
the pivot point,
and here is my gyroscope.
And the way I'm drawing things
is that r hat is this way,
is the top view, so
theta hat is that way,
and k hat is out of the screen.
So in the example
that I did earlier,
the angular momentum was
pointing in the plus r hat
direction.
So that's L sub s
pointing that way.
If the torque is pointing
in the theta hat direction,
then that's going to act to
rotate the angular momentum
vector this way.
And so the sense of
rotation will be like that.
And so in that case,
looking down on the system,
we would see a
counterclockwise rotation.
And that's equivalent to omega
vector pointing in the plus k
hat direction.
Alternatively, suppose
the wheel were spinning
in the other direction.
OK, so the sense of rotation
of this wheel around the axle,
we're in the opposite direction.
In that case, even when
the wheel was on this side
of the pivot --again,
this is a top view--
the angular momentum
vector would be pointing
in the opposite direction.
So now this is my
angular momentum vector.
It's pointing in the
opposite direction
that the axle is pointing.
Still along a line, but in
the minus R hat direction.
But the torque would still be
in the theta hat direction.
And so my new angular
momentum vector
would rotate this
way, which would
be equivalent to the axle
rotating in this direction.
And that's equivalent to a
rotation in the opposite sense,
clockwise as viewed
downward from the top,
or in other words, with capital
omega hat vector pointing
in the minus K hat direction.
So the direction of
precession depends
upon which way the
wheel is spinning,
which way the spin angular
momentum vector is actually
pointing.
Now, I'd just like to point out
that there's an approximation
that we've been making here.
I've alluded to it,
but I want to make
it very specific right now.
We have been assuming that the
spin angular momentum vector
L is large enough that
the torque vector, which
is perpendicular, provides
only a small angular
impulse that rotates L
without changing it in length.
Now, as L rotates,
the direction of r hat
and the direction of
theta rotate with it,
and the torque is always
in the theta hat direction.
So after any small delta T,
when the angular momentum
vector rotates, the
instantaneous torque
at that next instant is still
perpendicular to the rotating
momentum vector.
And so we're making
an approximation
that L is large enough
that we can consider
the instantaneous
angular impulse
as a small perpendicular
perturbation.
That's equivalent, it
turns out, to saying
that, so this is the
approximation that we're
making, that we've been
making so far, in this vector,
is that little omega, the
spin angular velocity,
is much, much
larger than capital
omega, the precession
angular velocity.
This is called the
gyroscopic approximation.
We'll see a more precise
statement of it later on.
But it's basically equivalent
to saying that the spin angular
momentum vector is so large
that we can consider the angular
impulse due to the
torque as causing
a pure rotation of the
vector without any change
in its length.
It's important to keep
in mind that a vector can
include both a
rotating component
and a constant component.
And in that case, it's important
to identify what the rotating
component is in order to use
the analysis that we presented
earlier.
So for example, let's consider
the case of a tilted gyroscope,
instead of one that's horizontal
and parallel to the ground.
So here is my pivot point.
That's the vertical.
And instead of a
horizontal gyroscope,
now I'll draw my gyroscope
at some angle like this.
Here's my wheel.
I'll call that angle
with the vertical phi.
This distance is still d.
And I'll use the usual
coordinate system,
that r hat is
pointing out this way,
k hat is pointing
vertically, and theta hat
is pointing into the screen.
Now, in this case, the gyroscope
will still process around
the vertical axis
to the pivot point,
and the angle phi
will remain constant.
Now, the angular momentum
vector due to spin points now
not in the r hat direction,
but again, outward along
the axis of rotation.
And that angular
momentum vector can
be decomposed into two
components, an r hat component
and a k hat component.
So in other words, my
angular momentum vector
can be written as the sum
of a vector pointing along
Z axis or the k hat direction
plus a vector pointing
in the radial direction.
I can also write that as L sub
z times k hat plus L sub r times
r hat.
Now, notice as this
gyroscope precesses
around, the z hat
component is constant,
but the r hat component
rotates around.
OK, so the r hat component,
the vector along the r hat
direction, is a purely
rotating vector,
whereas the z component
is a constant vector.
So L sub z is constant
and L sub r is rotating.
And so now, the
magnitude of dL dT,
which is equal to the magnitude
of dLz dT plus dLr dT,
well dLz dT, since that's a
constant vector, is just 0.
So the time derivative just
involves the r component.
And so that's equal to the
angular speed of rotation times
the length of the rotating
vector, which is just the r
component, not the z component.
So this is multiplied
by L sub r.
Now, in this particular
case, the r component
of the angular momentum vector
is L, the angular momentum
vector, times the sine of phi.
So in this particular case, this
would be omega times the full L
times the sine of phi.
So in the case
that we have here,
the angular momentum vector
consists of a constant part
and a rotating part.
And the magnitude of
its time derivative
is equal to the angular
velocity rotation
times the length of the
rotating part of the vector.